welcome from the Chess Club and classic
center of st. Louis this is Ryan and I'm
Katherine and this is splendored we make
mistakes so you don't have to Catherine
what kind of blunders do we have in
store today well grant our first game
actually has a double blunder much like
this show let's go to the board alright
first game is from blunders viewer
Antonio and in this position Antonio is
playing white now his opponent is about
to blunder by playing g6
this exposes the king and weakens the
King side now pause the video if you're
playing white what would you do
okay
Antonio picks the correct move and takes
on g6 black then takes the bishop on e5
I mean Tonio recaptures black finally
takes the bishop then white correctly
click the king in check by moving to g6
black blocks with 97 now here comes the
second blunder not sure what happened
Antonio but Queen b6 not a good move do
you like Evan
well Ryan I think is Queens going to be
captured it certainly it certainly is ah
that's a pretty rough wonder all right
while our next lender comes to us
courtesy of my co-host Ryan and this
game again chef star Johnson Shrunk
Johnson plays g4 what should you have
done here now don't speak yet Ryan let's
give the viewership a chance to think it
over
now what exactly Griffin the correct
move well I probably should have taken
on the G filed with Mike on on h3 but I
did not instead I played nice h4 at the
time I didn't understand why this is a
blunder hmm but do you get it now I get
it now Katherine I get it now well Ryan
let's give the viewers a chance to take
it over themselves
but what is it that you've done wrong
here
the problem here is that the knight is
attacked twice and it's only defended
once the bishop on e7 and the Queen on
d8 both attack the knife which is only
protected by the bishop on g3 this week
we only use one user-submitted blender
so Antonio you're going to get a double
signed picture of chest clear Fabiano
cara wanna catherine what does bring my
comer back me I got that for tonight
that's it doing here at funny gesture
sure a passed pawn brought home a fancy
car and his wife asked how are you old
afford that because don't worry I'm
about to be promoted
[Music]